I don't know how this sounds but I
actually don't care a whole lot about
this incident in the details of it and
what I care more about is the fact that
it was propagandized as a kind of as an
example of deliberate methodical
right-wing violence an attempt to
assassinate a Democrat by some Q Anon uh
Trump supporting person when just
everything we know about like the basic
facts of it say that that's that's not
true and at the same time that that's
happening you know Bill Maher does a
whole segment that this is a
continuation of the Cold War right this
is the Cold War in the United States
heating up he does this whole monologue
it's just absurd right yeah and as
that's happening you have a GOP
candidate I think his name is Pat
Harrigan uh whose house was was fired at
uh this happened in the last 24 hours
police kids almost died police confirmed
that someone shot uh into uh the home
where his parents live and I think his
kids were in the house at the time
and that's that's just one example right